welcome to this video yeah at least I'm
optimistic that this is a human being ii
m google jug you later this is the good
thing you know if you if you have this
title in the end the name yeah they are
not the name but okay if the title in
them he has proven to icc that this is
really i am this and that yam he's got
the name hidden here but it is an
international master and they have
records who this really is so this makes
[ __ ] on very much unlikely because
yeah at least then they have to weld
sheet and basically if they are reported
and so on everybody would know that a
specific player would have cheated so
it's a it's much less likely okay so we
have them and this came from sort of a
modern defense and I tried to play on
the dark squares which is basically
successful plate Bishop takes f3 to gain
more control over d4 and now I'm getting
this I wonder ever need to place if I
wanted to go with B 5 so I try to delay
if I for the moment I'm not really
worried about Bishop takes d4 here of
course okay so b5 oops be fired why not
so let's let's take and now c5 yep yeah
that shouldn't be shouldn't be bad right
looks like decent position Queen a5 is
threatening to take is this a good move
I don't know maybe threatening Queen c3
it's a very cheap trick of course but
it's not bad to play for a cheap trick
once in a while but well 97 I forgot
about that so I have to go back in jan
not ideal really not i mean i don't
think something terribly bad happened
but Queen 85 was kind of kind of useless
jump your later I've played this guy
before I've got a 50-person or two out
of two actually one in both games yeah
this is what I wanted yeah that kind of
filled with a for coming a for now or do
I need to or should I prepare it okay
let's do that if he takes it oh I pretty
playing badly yeah I mean I really
should see this move hmm that's that's
terrible we don't want to allow them to
play b5 now we enter and he also
threatens to take now of course
nida 5 you will check on c5 not just
terrible a for what a bad movie on
yeah what I'm trying to do is he a play
for compensation he has to play Queen
takes now I think and I take on c5 25 26
and I hope I can block on the dark
squares I'd really didn't want this b5
situation if he takes now I think I'm
okay getting in Bishop t45 should be
okay hmm I wonder does he have any
particular idea with that he hasn't
I'm a bit baffled here because this
looks completely not dangerous unless he
wants to sacrifice an exchange of
something after Bishop c5 okay so here
check check tending Roxy tool
hmm I really think I'm okay yeah maybe
I'm up too optimistic a check I will get
stuff back and whoopsie to question is
do I play here on ok now I'm going to
play for the the pawn directly check ok
so i can i can give the the checks now
for the draw can I do something can I do
more I get five this is this i can
always play I think ok so if i go
let's do that threatening ok one okay
now i can regain check this poem at
least time warning check check
yeah probably still a draw
yeah I cannot zoosk one game or anything
it's probably not probably no way to do
that maybe i can i can stay can invade
maybe I can still always play Bishop you
want to f1 Bishop e2 to everyone it's
really no no way forward draw our third
game yeah man I cannot do anything I
don't don't don't see anything yeah i
don't know i always get this counter
play hear me I mean here here it's
really the question if I can play for
win the computer says so but now with
the with the time and so on i wanted to
want it to play it safe check check now
this is the draw really i'm a but other
I wonder still wondered about here if
maybe like g5g for this kind of thing or
also Bishop b5 if those moves but ok the
airport now a draw is probably probably
okay yeah i was i was a bit more afraid
that that he would move the queen of
course yeah to e3 or something this is
also stronger i think here this is
helping me considerably once i get them
I think I'm okay how to tell I mean
maybe you find something with precise
precise analysis but I have this counter
play and the spawn is not not that
important
okay wow thanks for watching